[Musique]
oui bien apparent avec annecy 6 min
seulement à lundi depuis 7 semaines je
dois parler d'un enjeu qui me trouble
énormément c'est l'histoire de cette
jeune fille autochtone qui viennent la
nouvelle écosse je ne nommerai pas vous
comprendrez vraiment pourquoi elle qui
malheureusement était enlevée et dont le
manque de réactivité de la police de
nouvelle écosse pour lancer une alerte
amber l'excusent ayant été donnée que
probablement que la jeune fille de 14
ans était parti de son plein gré avec
l'homme qui était suspecté de l'avoir
enlevée sur les 8 47 faut pas oublier
qu'une alerte amber peut-être lancé à
n'importe quel moment où on soupçonne
disparition d'un jeune de moins de 18
ans
que l'on pense que sa vie est en danger
qui contient une description adéquate
toit du suspect soit du véhicule dans
lequel elle a été enlevée et tout ça
combiné n'a pas quand même fait
déclencher une alerte amber
il fallut que la communauté s'active que
le conseil de bande s'activent pour
pouvoir faire en sorte que la nouvelle
sorte en partant le charge de cette
jeune fille et après directeur qui est
je m'excuse mais était inadéquate
puisqu'on sait que chaque heure compte
dans un cas d'enlèvement
après le temps qu'ils avaient été
nécessaires pour commencer à faire une
alerte et bien on s'attendre plus a
trouvé le corps d'une personne d'une
victime
par chance la jeune fille a été retrouvé
sain et sauf
et comme de fait présentement il ya
assez de de fait pour pouvoir dire qu'il
y aurait peut-être des accusations qui
vont être portées contre l'homme puisque
ce serait peut-être justement un cas
d'enlèvement mais il y aura fallu
retrouver la personne quelle qu'elle
puisse dire oui et ça n'enlève mans pour
un euro c'était un enlèvement finalement
et ça ça fait ressortir tous les enjeux
que l'on essaie de faire mettre en
lumière depuis les dernières
des deux décennies sur les femmes
assassinées despair cet enjeu qui fait
que les femmes autochtones quand ils
viennent au monde au canada en caisse
pour cent et même plus de chances de
mourir ou d'être victimes d'un acte de
violence physique ou sexuelle
donc en étant nées femmes autochtones au
canada on augmente nos chances de
disparaître
et malheureusement que aucune recherche
sera enclenchée ça le fait de sortir un
corps et même de cas qui ont été
extrêmement important au québec mais qui
ont bénéficié de très très peu de
couvertures médiatiques ou même de
recherches policières je pense un maisy
odjick et shannon alexander qui
malheureusement aujourd'hui encore
demain disparu on n'a pas retrouvé aucun
indice
et pourtant ces jeunes filles quand
elles ont disparu on la police se dire
c'est des fugueuses elles vont venir
d'ici quelques jours
alors que leurs effets personnels
avaient été laissées derrière donc les
familles et eric est mais pas assez
c'était pas sympa pour qu'on enclenche
des recherches et je me rappelle à cette
époque quand c'est cette recherche
justement ses deux jeunes fils on essayé
de la mettre en lumière on essaie de
faire prendre la tension médiatique
c'était vraiment énormément et c'est
dans cette rencontre est difficile pour
les communautés locales de faire un fond
de leurs enjeux si on bloquait pas de
hip hop et bien dans la même année il y
avait eu dans les nouvelles boom 1 le
lion qui dans la même communauté
diby avait des parties partie la maison
dans laquelle il avait été retenu un
petit gant est là et policiers s'étaient
mis en branle bas de combat
les nouvelles étaient arrivés il y avait
des files il y avait des détecteurs de
mouvements de détecteurs thermiques et
celles à ce moment là elle sait pas que
j'ai dit si jamais moi je disparais
dites leur que je suis un lion parce
qu'ils ne chercheront pas céder à ce
point justement le stigma d'être une
femme autochtone qui disparaît peut être
inquiétant et veut dire une différence
entre la vie et la mort et d'ailleurs
dans les médias un concept réussi c'est
à dire le syndrome de la femme blanche
disparu c'est là on parle quand une
femme blanche disparaît on va savoir le
nom de sa famille son nom le nom toucher
l'histoire on veut humaniser énormément
l'histoire de cette femme alors fait
conseillers ont retrouvé le corps d'une
femme autochtone ou à une autre femme
autochtone a été retrouvé une femme a
été retrouvée assassinée le corps d'une
femme autochtone et on ne savait jamais
le nom la provenance et vers une
déshumanisation totale des écoles de
disparition ou d'assassinât de ferme
autochtone c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a
permis que rabat pecten le célèbre tueur
en série en colombie-britannique a pu
faire des assassinats pendant si
longtemps parce qu'ils visaient
principalement des prostituées dis donc
on essaye de vancouver donc tous ces
enjeux le viennent en 2020 faire
ressortir justement cette blessure sept
7 membres
ce manque de confiance qui existe
justement entre les communautés
autochtones et les forces policières
comme décor pour ce qui concerne les
femmes autochtones vont ressortir et là
on voit aussi une montée aux états unis
du mouvement aussi des femmes
assassinées disparu parce que ce n'est
pas une question uniquement canadienne
une question aussi américaine c'est ici
aussi au mexique
c'est une problématique mondiale quand
on parle de femmes autochtones on
souvent hyper sexualisée le corps des
femmes autochtones comme un hyper
sexualisée le corps des femmes noires à
l'époque de la colonisation
d'ailleurs dans les premiers des
premiers recueils historique on disait
comment les jeunes filles autochtones et
libéré
comment il était coutume hypersexuel
parce que justement on avait des valeurs
beaucoup plus libre que celle judéo
chrétienne qui arrivait dans le bateau
malheureusement c'est une main je
continue et on peut le voir par exemple
quand on fait la nar le narratif de
pocahontas par exemple qui était une
jeune fille préadolescente adolescente
qui est estimé aux alentours de 12 13
ans alors qu'aujourd'hui on l'a ou là
mais encore souvent dans les films dans
les bandes dessinées comme une jeune
femme très libérées sexuelle les cheveux
au vent manque une épaule à sa robe
c'est c'est s'aider problématique des
enjeux qui touchent à beaucoup de
niveaux les femmes si je peux vous
recommander un documentaire à écouter ça
serait ce si l'institut de kimonos mme
sahlin qui est un bijou pour transférer
justement cette douleur pour pouvoir
faire comprendre l'enjeu et humaniser
justement les femmes autochtones et de
comprendre d'où vient ce stigma
continuelle et comment il a été empirée
par les pensionnats parle sixties coup
par la colonisation par la
discrimination systémique existe autour
des enjeux autochtones
alors vous comprendrez que c'est un
sujet qui est normal ou énormément
personnel aussi quand on est une femme
autochtone comme une main au docteur une
grand-mère autochtone chaque jour est un
jour d'inquiétude pour nos enfants
alors ça je pense que s'il devrait y
avoir eu une mission en 2020 c'est de
continuer à pousser pour ce que les
femmes autochtones au canada et les
femmes qui vient soit des historiques de
colonisation soit de l'immigration se
sentent en sécurité d'être des femmes au
canada
alors je remercie beaucoup pour votre
écoute j'espère que vous n'hésiterez pas
à partager ses vidéos
je vous souhaite une belle semaine